you either dwell on it for the rest of
your life and decide the reason you
weren't successful in life is because
when you were 19 your brother stole
$8,000 from you or you put that chip on
your shoulder and you get more motivated
than ever and you go harder
[Music]
every minutes accounted for so when I'm
on I'm on it's 15 hours tight all in
mourning tonight period what I know is I
know that how the platforms work when
you have a direct ask at the end when
it's about go fill this out go donate
you've taken 50% of the energy out of
the piece of content when there's an ask
in the same time that there is a setup
you've lost equity the charming guy at
the bar who was a very nice one our
conversation if his last thing out of
his mouth psyched all right you want to
come upstairs he kind of defeated a lot
of the set up whereas if you're just but
this is the way I think about it right
but like this is a very good way to
think about it cuz it's very universal
and every human understands it had that
then turned into another date and
another date the mission could have been
accomplished for whatever the agenda was
at hand that's where I want you to go
because you have to understand why every
person that reads and consumes that I
can cookie and retarget them and ask
them separately in a different
environment
it's not like a gala in a gala when red
our highest emotion yes that you know in
the moment not digitally yeah got it
digitally I've got that it's like if I
went to the gal at the highest emotion
but you put a little bug on me and you
could talk to me all the time you see
it's a different it's a different setup
hey guys thank you so much we'll be in
touch yeah that's right I think for all
of you the truth is always the answer I
think you should I think you should test
an education and a like you're teaching
and you're keeping up with them but
you're doing it tactically I'm not
talking about a mastermind you know I'm
not talking about like we like details
like like the way this is formulated
like you're gonna get the real details
like it's just details so I think if
you're able to continue to educate
people on details like wide it's that
snapchat changed last week so now
there's new details I'm playing with it
everyday and my whole thesis that I told
everybody for the last two years of like
don't give up last year don't give up on
snapchat because if they make them my
snapchat consumptions up a hundred
percent because they changed the UI and
they're favoring personalities now
anyway like that like linkedin made a
change facebook ads change in ceramics
organic reach drop like in the world we
plan there is a need for constant weekly
updated with everything and like it took
him and everybody else like whoa this
guy plays it different Mazel Tov but
then you bet the reason I do that is I
don't want to give ammo to anybody Drake
the commercial with his liquor or his
dad punks him is why Drake wins
Drake smart Drake really understands
Drake knows that he's gonna be hated on
for his style of hack there pretty boy
singer rapper so he I think Drake more
than anybody uses the 8-mile thesis up
he's gonna make fun of himself you know
why Drake can't lose a battle
cuz he's gonna [ __ ] on himself there's
nothing meek or anybody else can say
he's gonna say it so you can't say you
can't rap you say it's already over
honestly here's what's up like I want to
start a show called
and I've been thinking about this I'm
gonna call it and people gonna call in
tell me their problem and I'm gonna say
and it's a good show right like tell me
anything
both my parents were crackheads and like
I lost my job and my husband's beating
me and look these are real [ __ ] I'm not
[ __ ] saying these are small things
these are the hardest things in life
here's my question
life's about alternatives what the [ __ ]
are you gonna do about it leave your
husband I get it
you live in a house that's nice and you
don't know how to work and you've never
worked but you want to get punched their
face absolutely not that's [ __ ]
unacceptable and I'm gonna make sure you
make me continue of the end shell ready
P listen but you don't understand like
my my brother my older brother he I had
$8,000 I've been working three jobs and
he walked in my room and stole it and
left
that's it no no no no just ask and and
and you either dwell on it for the rest
of your life and decide the reason you
weren't successful in life is because
when you were 19 your brother stole
$8,000 from you or you put that chip on
your shoulder and you get more motivated
than ever and you go harder no [ __ ] you
know what you know I I don't I'm not
[ __ ] normal
I get disappointed and frustrated but
actually thinking like I'm always macro
optimistic like I got life the [ __ ] do I
have to be I'm in control I think people
are depressed when they don't have
things into context they don't realize
how lucky they have it and two they
don't feel in control it's tough I don't
get depressed I get I get I get critical
on my actions I get thoughtful when I'm
in a bad place I'm like okay what am i
doing that's wrong like but listen my
chemical listen this is an illness
some people have chemicals that like
this is about my brain is right like I
have to be thankful for that but here's
my thing I don't know how to teach how
to get people out of depression I'm just
trying to change people's perspective
it's awfully hard to give when you have
nothing to give it's awfully hard to dig
I've come to realize Wow that's right I
realized I was so talented everything's
a foregone conclusion that I'm able to
give more than I take because I don't
need anything from anybody I can get it
myself when you're self fulfilling you
become super dangerous in the slang term
of like you've got all the leverage
I do a hundred percent and I think the
key with me when I say I'm more of it
than anybody ever met I mean what I'm
about to tell you
nobody has ever disappointed me in my
entire life it's a really important like
concept that I don't speak to a lot
nobody has ever let me down nobody has
ever let me down baby
nobody has ever let me down no it's
actually neither it's a it's I have zero
expectation of others mm-hmm and that's
I think what I'm realizing is the purest
form of giving without expectation like
I don't eat I don't give more to you and
then I give to your daughter because you
have more to give to me back it's just I
look at you two the same it's a very
weird game man like I equally think that
sucks can do as much for me as Schnucks
because I don't know how it all plays
out but way more importantly it's not
even that strategic I'm not looking for
the other part I mean this is real and I
think it's a match brother like when we
when we meet right yeah you meet me at
an interesting point when we meet which
is I have a new baby called Vayner
sports and you have a lot of leverage to
give to me even in that moment I can't
get excited about the thought of like
print pro quo or like I'm gonna give to
him because in two years he'll give like
it just doesn't run through my mind I
don't want to meet anybody like I'm
about to meet the amazing all-time
Warren Moon I wanna say one thing which
is the ninety one playoff game against
the Jets really pissed me off more and I
don't want to be your friend like it's
not gonna be it's not it's not it's not
it's a very weird game it's it's a
strength and a weakness it's why I also
don't have mentors and have left a lot
of opportunity on the table so when I'm
on I'm on it's 15 hours tight all in
mourning tonight period right but when
I'm off for one of our Jets game
or when it's vacation time I'm off and I
can shut it off and on and I'm winning
in those extremes and I believe there's
more of that allowed than people think
because I think people are being half
pregnant of both like they want to work
life balance and they're working 9:00 to
5:00 they're coming home or they think
like I don't know I just think people
have it confused I think there's more
victories than the extremes and that's
how you balance sound it's like a bridge
a bridge is [ __ ] extreme you get
across from one side to the other is a
big [ __ ] ocean in the middle and
they're pulling hard as [ __ ] from those
two opposite sides that's how I think of
myself and I'm trying to teach that a
little bit remember the new rule of
three snapchat pieces of content oh you
weren't in the meeting you were you were
bouncing around when we had our biggest
meeting ever
guys I'm supposed to be doing way more
snapchat content but babban wasn't there
for a big meeting last Friday because he
was just bullshitting so sorry about
that it's it's my fault
ultimately but let's also tweet out boo
babban hit me up on twitter and go boo
babban like it's one thing if like you
know how we got into this cadence he
wanted to show something on his big
computer right
but I'm always I feel like with no joke
I'm obviously making jokes it's more
about them getting their full meeting if
I'm left to meet getting down there
they're in deep [ __ ] and we always lose
whereas if they're here I feel like
they're losing 10 minutes every meeting
you know what I mean
now on the flip side I should probably
go down there because it's like the few
times I actually get downstairs so
there's also that so it's a real tough
decision Alex you make the call you have
to pull from opposite directions yes
by what oh I have a gold plate one now
cousin okay I love how I don't even know
what you choose okay and like people's
entire lives are about getting if you
didn't point to that I had no shot okay
what do you think I think I what no
d-roc one scare I want do you rock you
love this we're going with Gary Vee I
feel like I have a Gary Vaynerchuk so
let's go with Gary Vee I was actually
smiling because basically my shtick is
to razz with you and I'm like happy for
you that you won this round
Congrats the rock by the way by the way
actually this just happened we are not
doing enough of the human stuff in the
vlog like this stuff happens every day
and it's not in the blog because we're
staying very prescriptive to bring value
I think breaking up you know or maybe
I'm also not watching that much so this
is a little bit of my perception but
what's that um you and I are always on
the same page
babban that's exactly when you should be
filming something for snapchat but once
again even though I magic
you're a big boy you should have been
able to like the fact that you weren't
able to pick up on the nuances of what
the rule was I know you know what the
rule was I said to you
what [ __ ] rule like like what was
confusing of hey bro I even said the
number I said hey we're supposed to make
three that I literally forbade them said
to you can you please recall it for the
vlog right now mavin remember the new
rule of three
snapchat piece of content oh you weren't
in the meeting and then I even made a
snap about it boo Babin and now I just
brought it up again that's exactly when
you should be filming something for
snapchat and you claim that you don't
know what's going on kids
excuses are always the wrong answer
[Music]